precision medicine is changing the way
we understand diagnose and treat cancer
the transformation is driven by high
throughput molecular data from patients
animal models and large-scale cell line
experiments in this program we will
explore how the various tommix data
types can be analyzed to understand the
basic biology associated with cancer
onset development and outcomes the
program will start March 9th and
continue until May 16th during this time
we will learn to apply analysis of
genomic and transcriptomic data to the
study of breast cancer biology the
program speakers will offer insights
into various aspects of cancer research
and offer guided training on the use of
the analytical tools that are used to
process analyze and interpret data from
public repositories in the introductory
section of the program we will touch on
oncology as a field and in addition
we'll be discussing challenges
associated with big data in cancer
research
we will start by speaking about cancer
biology at the cell and tissue levels
we're going to be breaking down the
complexity of tumor development as well
as the rules of the tumor
microenvironment in the introductory
section of the program will touch on
oncology as a field as well as the
challenges that are associated with big
data in cancer research we're also going
to be speaking about DNA genes and RNA
transcription we will also learn about
basic and translational research in
oncology where patient derive cell lines
xenograph models and clinical trials
offer rich collections of data that are
used in order to inform the diagnosis
and treatment of cancer in patients the
recent growth and high-throughput
sequencing of cancer genomes as well as
transcriptomes have produced a big data
problem this big data problem precludes
many cancer biologists as well as
oncologists from gleaning knowledge from
data regarding the nature and lignin
processes as well as the relationship
between tumor genomic profiles and
treatment responses that's what we will
learn about these data types as well as
how to both efficiently process and
analyze such information we will do so
by learning about DNA variation
such a single nucleotide polymorphisms
and copy number variation will do this
by analyzing NGS genomic data such as
whole exome or whole genome sequencing
we will also spend considerable time
learning about gene expression and RNA
seek practicing each of the analysis
steps on the user-friendly T bio info
platform when we start the analysis we
have a library of unstructured data the
output from the pipeline is going to be
called structured data where the columns
are sample names and the rows are gene
or isoform ids in insolvable format
inside each cell will finally quantified
expression levels will also be learning
how to apply statistical approaches such
as regression the study differences
between conditions that have multiple
factors this will allow us to find
relationships in the data as well as
find significant genes that are
associated with cancer types or stages
these genes are the ones people use in
biological interpretation using several
methods that will help us gain a
systematic understanding of found
changes in expression one of these
methods we will learn about is gene set
enrichment analysis this is a process
that can map certain genes to identify
enriched pathways that are activated
deactivated or deregulated these
pathways will give us insights into the
biology of tumor development as well as
the interactions that are occurring
within the micro environment we'll take
a dataset from the publication titled
modeling precision treatment of breast
cancer which was featured in genome
biology in 2013 the publication is
interesting because the authors
assembled a data set of about 50
different breast cancer cell lines the
represent of the whole spectrum of
breast cancer variations these cell
lines have genomic transcriptomics and
proteomics data as well as an efficacy
measurement of the commonly used and
experimental cancer drugs we're also
going to be reviewing some of the data
resources as well as databases that you
can leverage in your research projects
to apply what we've learned in order to
analyze data from cancer patients we
will review the most comprehensive
collections of omics as well as clinical
data that's found in the Cancer Genome
Atlas or TCGA learning to navigate the
genomic data Commons portal to find
via omics data sets with clinical
information about the samples we'll take
the samples from the liver
hepatocellular carcinoma project and
then we'll see how various clinical data
that is available for these patients can
be used in the analysis of bull gene
expression as well as for micro RNA we
welcome you to join us for this program
and learn about the application of
bioinformatics and precision oncology we
will leverage our top-rated online
tutorials with smart tracking of
activity as well as curated datasets
that are designed for a great learning
experience will also be leveraging easy
to use analytical tools that one can
access and utilize without any technical
background in bioinformatics or coding
at the end of the program participants
will receive a certificate of
participation
this program will start March 9th and
continue until May 16th
there are discounted registration rates
that are available for early
registration